yemen's suffering is most war in its
children but twelve years old
Abdul weighs 11 kilograms little more
than the average one-year-old every step
he takes is painful and he's been kept
alive by the tube through his nose into
his stomach two of his brothers are also
emaciated but his family's poor and
they're spending the little money they
have trying to save him right now he's
desperately hungry but he's so
malnourished
it's an enormous effort trying to
swallow and he doesn't manage it
his despair and his wretchedness is not
isolated near Yemen's northern border
with Saudi Arabia they've suffered some
of the worst destruction of the war in
parts of Sadr City
no buildings been left untouched the
airstrikes for nearly two years now by
the saudi-led coalition are backed by
Britain America and France parts of
Yemen have been bombed back to the
Middle Ages the director of this boys
school wants an international
investigation into why children's
education centres are being attacked
this is a big crime a war crime because
this is an educational area with no
weapons they are affecting education
they want to stop students learning
the boys school was hit in 11 times the
- deep pop marks in the earth aware - if
the bombs landed when the boys were
moved to the nearby girls school that
was attacked - could British weapons
have been used by the Saudis to bomb
civilian targets the Yemenis believe so
first we thought Britain was a friend
but now we feel the British government
are criminals because of what's
happening here they're committing crimes
killing children pregnant women in
amongst American cluster bombs in Sadr
City we found a nose cone for the
British made storm shadow cruise missile
arguably the most advanced weapon of its
kind if you open in the middle this
looks
this has definitely got a UK UK the
remnant was found in solder four days
earlier
the locals are adamant they've been hit
by British cluster bombs too we were
shown pictures of UK made cluster bombs
said to have been found in the city and
now circulating amongst Yemenis Britain
agreed six years ago to ban them and
stop their use by anyone else because he
said we have found previously a lot of
bombs Britain bombs
that's why I think so Yemen bomb
disposal teams can't keep pace with the
air onslaught and British bombs keep on
turning up it's from UK he says the
hootie rebels new prime minister gave
his first interview since his
appointment to Sky News and immediately
accused Britain of war crimes in Yemen
battle cannibal
al qadir they have solved the cluster
bombs for Saudi Arabia we're tired of
being adenine and she and there you know
exactly they are going to drop them here
in Yemen humid outside and saw the
province were falafel on different
provinces la canal hakumen Beretania
estaba el Holly
Costa Rica tan ma I do a Cerruti already
lots of wooden aluminum with the ex
government of Britain and the current
ones are participating with the pumping
and air strikes in Yemen so you think
they're guilty of war crimes in your
eyes Britain is also guilty of war
crimes and I thought with Anna
Norman and Home Minister Akeem Ishita
our compassion well get him out of that
yeah he doesn't think so he believes
that they are war crimes because they
are they are participating
the war has meant more than half the
country is short of food that's 40
million people the reality for children
is even worse faizal's just one of the
staggering 300,000 toddlers in Yemen
starving to death but to his mother he's
not a statistic he's her two-year-old
son she just doesn't have the means to
help him Ghani is so weak herself she
doesn't react as her eight month old
baby thrashes around in pain she's been
feeding her little girl on just winter
and flower milk is an unobtainable
luxury the roads are peppered with women
and children reduced to begging for
scraps from passing strangers the
destruction of the infrastructure and
the blockade on imports has been
crippling the hootie rebel areas and
those in them are now running out of
cash so the medics at the main hospital
in the capital sana are working now
unpaid you know system back in this
hospital we have in any salaries they
gave us last month half salary of
September the UK educated doctor is now
dealing with a significant outbreak of
cholera it's been caused by their
compromised hygiene and the widespread
lack of clean water amongst the
desperately ill patients a boy with no
name abandoned by his parents who
couldn't cope with war and a sick child
who's now brain damaged
he's been here for 10 months being cared
for by nurse Pfizer who loves him like
her own but we don't know what to do we
cannot to just throw him in the human
being even his handicap cannot swim
as the desperation grows so does the
anger thousands turned out at Sanna to
show their support for a new hoody
government for these people there's no
way back for president Hadi the man they
hounded out of the Capitol and who Saudi
is supporting the chance against America
a growing stronger and also is that
hatred against all those taking part or
even supporting this coalition of
bombing Britain is making fresh enemies
whether or not it's a proxy war between
Saudi and its regional rival Iran even
those who don't support the Hootie's now
detest America and Britain this conflict
could be storing up dangerous problems
for the future Alex Crawford Sky News in
cootie controlled Yemen
[Music]